professor bogdan all there's been a lot
of talk about legitimacy if there is a
hung parliament ie now the label not
conservatives have an overall majority
who has the right or the legitimacy to
former government who has the right to
form a government in those circumstances
is a matter of opinion legitimacy is
subjective there are clear
constitutional rules about who does form
a government and that depends upon who
can command the support of the House of
Commons that's decided by the Queen
speech now legitimacy is the question of
whether people like the outcome they
might well not and of course if they're
predicting a certain outcome that might
affect the way they vote if they don't
like it when it comes about they might
vote differently next time but the
constitutional rules are absolutely
clear whether people like the outcome or
not is another question a lot of
conservative supporters and say look if
David Cameron is the leader of the
largest party he will have probably got
the single party that's got the most
votes surely it should be him who forms
government well yes if he can command a
majority support in the House of Commons
if you can't then no you can't form the
government simply having most seats if
you haven't reached the winning line
doesn't enable you to to form a
government because you can't win votes
in the House of Commons fundamentally
it's can you command the confidence of
the house if you haven't got a majority
then you can't it may well be that
although egg Miliband may end up with
fewer seats there is a greater array of
other parties that are more left of
center if you like who are more inclined
to support him than they are support
concerns so what about in in the
immediate aftermath of an election who
gets to try the confidence of the House
of Commons first assuming that Ed
Miliband says look there's a progressive
alliance which has majority and David
Cameron says well actually I you know I
am the largest leader of the largest
party I think I should go what happens
then the first decision is that of David
Cameron as the incumbent Prime Minister
he can either resign immediately or he
can try and form a coalition or
agreement with another party or parties
or he can test the feeling of parliament
by presenting a program in the Queen's
Speech and
whether it's voted down or not but as to
the question of legitimacy let's say he
gets thirty six percent of the vote and
labor gets thirty-four percent of vote
for ultimate sake is it legitimate for
him to be able to govern alone when
sixty-four percent of the country voted
against him I mean when you are so much
below fifty percent as Ruth Fox is
implying a moment to go should you be
allowed to govern without having the
support of other parties I mean that was
the point about the deal which was done
last time between labor delivery Liberal
Democrats and conservatives was that
they when they got together and had a
formal agreement they had a clear
majority so does that mean Ruth that
actually it's better to form a coalition
than to try and go with a minority as
absolutely mobile the party leaders seem
to say they're inclined to do not
necessarily and it depends on the
numbers and it depends how how the
parties feel in terms of policy issues I
mean the reality of minority government
though if that is the way they go that's
what Ed Miliband's set his mind to is in
a five-year Parliament minority
government will be very very difficult
to sustain day-to-day vote two votes
over that period frankly could be
exhausting so they might get to sort of
period and think we wish we had to had
the coalition if we could have put the
numbers together but the numbers have
got to work for him for that attack to
happen and how much control of this
situation do the leaders of the other
parties have I mean Nikolas third is not
even standing this election she said no
deals with the Tories Nick Clegg Lee
said well I could go either way could he
really go either way yes if a party
could go either way it has leverage
there are only two parties which can do
that the Liberal Democrats and the
Democratic Unionist of Northern Ireland
the SNP can't afford to undermine a
Labour government it would ruin their
position in Scotland you Kip can't
really afford to undermine a
conservative guy but there is some
process all of them said of consulting
their own party members well I think
they've announced their position and
that stops them having much leverage but
of course it would be better as you
imply the moment ago if you could get a
coalition because the last government a
coalition whatever one thinks of the
merits of its policies which obviously
are a matter of opinion it did provide
strong stable government with a majority
of 78 over a period of five years that
raised a very different quest
legitimacy I think because it was formed
after the election and people who voted
liberal Democrat in 2010 were not aware
that there would be a coalition with the
conservative most of them I suspect were
on the left and hoped for a coalition
with labour and you may remember if
you've got a long memory as I'm sure you
have the Guardian recommended a vote for
Liberal Democrats to secure what they
called a progressive coalition that can
come about was that legitimate was
interesting now we've got several
newspapers calling for a repeat of the
lib dem conservative coalition but Ruth
what about this idea that if you don't
have the party that comes first in a
coalition in a government effectively
you've got a so-called coalition of the
losers well only if you look at politics
in a very binary labour versus
conservative way but what this is why
we're in new territory because we've got
fragmented politics multi-party politics
if you look at both the percentage of
votes and the seats but there will be a
majority but is anti conservative most
probably we won't know till Friday but
probably they'll be majority at Santa
conservatives that's not that's not
about winning and losing that's only if
you look at it from a very very clear
labor versus consider she's born all
this down does this mean on the basis of
what we know now about the opinion polls
are the Constitution everything else it
looks roughly speaking 5050 whether it's
going to be Miliband or I think that's
absolutely right I think Ruth has made a
fundamental point that our political
culture may be changing people talk the
second election but would that yield a
very different result if our political
culture is changing and we're moving
into a multi-party system perhaps we
ought to look critically at a lot of our
institutions including the electoral
system our parliamentary arrangements
and so on which were really designed for
a two-party battle that perhaps is a
fundamental challenge facing the pond
after the election I don't both you'll
be on hand with sage advice in those
circumstances thank you very much indeed